he must be here somewhere
roberto arta sanchez is hot on his trail
europe's largest predator is at home in
the woodlands of northern spain
there was a bear here no doubt about it
no other animal would climb up a cherry
tree and break off a branch
just for the fruit
roberto has proof he works for a
wildlife conservation association
and has installed surveillance cameras
in spots where bears
visit frequently
he loves watching the behavior of wild
bears when they're feeling undisturbed
there they are that makes me so happy it
tells me this is one more place where
the species feels at home again
bears have died out in large parts of
europe here
they've survived to people like us
that's wonderful
even here in the cantabrian mountains
brown bears nearly became extinct
today there are about 300 of them in
these parts the biggest population of
bears in western europe
but the numbers are problematic too the
animals have been entering people's
properties in search of food
in maria sanriesco's garden in rio one
took an entire cherry tree
the bear came and ate everything he
didn't leave a single cherry behind
and we were just about to harvest them
now it's too late 90
in km a bear has been making daily
visits to a restaurant storage room
the owner jose gonzalez filmed the bear
trying to get into a barrel of old
cooking oil
he says he'll store the oil in the
garage from now on
but he also wants more protection
we've got to chase the bears away and
see to it that they don't come into our
village anymore
that's vital lots of children and
elderly live here in the summer
there could be an incident an incident
like the one a few weeks before
when a bear took a 75 year old woman by
surprise
and seriously injured her biologists
operating a refuge for injured and
behaviorally abnormal bears
examined the case they're convinced that
confrontations with such serious
consequences
are very rare
normally bears run away from people in
this case
it attacked the woman because it felt
threatened the woman broke her hip
during the attack and her face was
injured
bears are not aggressive or dangerous
per se that was an unfortunate encounter
roberto and his association want to
identify suspect bears
and observe their behavior in order to
step in if needed
the conservationist knows why the
predators have lost their fear of humans
there's less and less farming in the
villages meadows and pastures are
reverting back into forests
so now many villages are right in the
middle of the woods
the bear isn't really exiting the forest
when it approaches a village
it's staying in its habitat it's
important we take a closer look at
what's really going on here instead of
just blaming the animals for anything
that goes wrong
to keep the bears out of the villages
the conservationists want to ensure that
the animals find plenty of food far away
from civilization
that's why roberto and his colleagues
are planting fruit trees in woodland
clearings
in the coming decades we want to make it
possible for bears and humans to
co-exist
we want to sensitize people to the fact
that bears belong here
just like we people do and that
conflicts are very rare
raising awareness to dispel fear the
love for bears
it would seem is all a matter of
perspective
and proper distancing
you